on today's show we talked to a woman
whose brother called her husband a
racist
it is that complicated we also talked to
a man whose best friend
may be having an affair and he doesn't
know how to address it
and finally we talked to a kind man
whose wife
just changed religions on him and
they've got two kids
navigating a messy situation and by the
way
i screwed up mark cohen's lyrics stay
tuned
what up what up i am john and this is
the dr
john dolone show where we take your
calls about your life
your relationships your kids your mental
and relational health
all of it we talk about all of it i want
to help you rethink
re-examine and reconsider your lives how
you talk to yourself
how you talk to those you love how you
talk to those who hate
who you hate i guess not who hate who
hate who hate everybody i don't know
talk to everybody
how do you talk to anybody and everybody
how to boldly take the next crooked
wobbly step towards whatever is next in
your life
we're going to talk about integrity we
may talk about loss we may talk about
when things just fall
apart let me talk about infidelity
finding love again
and today we're gonna do something new i
got a new segment and i didn't even talk
to
james childs we got a news segment
called
the geek minute how about that does that
sound good
i love it all right you sound like
you're just overwhelmed so here's the
thing for so many reasons
i want to talk about science and for so
many reasons science has such a bad rap
these days if you say the word science
it instantly means you're all these
other things
and so i want to take a cue from a
couple of folks dr rhonda patrick
who is does a great job she's out there
in the internet's world she's brilliant
and she does a great job distilling
science hard concepts into
easily digestible tidbits and then dr
peter at if you don't listen to his
podcast the drive you should
it's excellent but he does again does a
great job taking very complex things and
distilling them down
dr tia has a segment on one of his blogs
he used to have years ago called the
nerd safari
and i loved it because me and my friends
in higher ed we all called ourselves
nerds we're a bunch of research nerds
so we're i was sitting around trying to
think of what we could call a segment
where
we i take a study and distill it down
for practical use for normal people not
for scientists not for
other nerds not for conspiracy theories
but just
here's a study that is out that you
could use in your life to make your life
better and there's usually a 30 to 20
sometimes as quick as 15 year lag
on when a study comes out and it
actually makes its way into mainstream
media in the mainstream life right and i
want to i want to
close that gap in a significant way 25
years is just too long
it's just too long right so we're
thinking about what should be called
like nerd safari and we can't do that
because the dr t
is the like he's just the best and he's
way out there
and so i was sitting here thinking and i
remember being in a meeting with
everybody and
and saying guys i got it i got it we're
gonna call this
the geek squad and i
i thought i'd stumble onto something
great and i think someone gently said
like
yeah that's cool it was really cool the
first time
um best buy came up with it for all of
the people who come to your house and
fix your electronics and then i felt
like an idiot
so we're going to call it the geek
minute because i'm just going to take a
minute
and i don't want to use nerds and i
don't want to use anything else we're
just going to use geeks
if you've got a better title for this
little segment this little scientific
segment let me know i'm happy to change
it but for today it's the geek minute so
here it is
in the last show i talked about we're
gonna do we're doing
30 days no sugar from january 7th to
february 7th
by now you're a couple days into it and
your life is probably terrible it
probably hurts unless you're hardcore
and you snap into a slim gym and you're
one of those tough guys
it'll get you later but um this comes to
me
dr patrick sent this via her newsletter
but it's a study that came out
in september of 2020. charlotte
deborah's is the chief investigator on
this out of the american journal of
clinical nutrition
so we all know that excessive sugar
intake the article
says is now recognized as a key factor
for obesity type 2 diabetes
cardiovascular disease
so i hope you recognize that the science
of nutrition already knows sugar is the
culprit it's the bottom line
problem with so many issues
but it went on to suggest that because
of the way cancer works
could sugar play a major role in the
development and
sustainability of cancer so this study
looked at
a hundred in one thousand participants
that's a lot the median age was 41 years
old
and they they adjusted for
sociodemographic
anthropo anthropometic lifestyle medical
history and nutritional factors
what that means is sometimes a study
comes out and they
somebody will say well that's just
because it used real unhealthy people or
really overweight people it really
fit people this study is saying that
they
looked at all of those things they
adjusted for
all of the different body types and
lifestyle factors and ages and medical
histories nutritional factors
and here's what they found no big shock
but
total sugar intake was associated with
higher overall cancer risk
in addition and i'm reading directly
significant associations with cancer
risk were also observed for added sugars
free sugars sucrose sugars from milk
based desserts
dairy products and sugary drinks and
that includes coke that includes orange
juice
and before you dairy non-dairy people
send you me your mean cards and letters
just know that they're talking about the
lactose
the breakdown of dairy products is the
sugar there
and they went on to write these results
suggest that sugars may represent a
modifiable risk factor for cancer
prevention particularly breast cancer
contributing to the current debate on
the implementation
now get this here's where this is all
headed
sugar taxation marketing regulations and
other sugar-related policies
and so once they determine that
cigarettes will kill you you know if you
look at the package it's
a huge warning they've got a bajillions
of dollars worth of taxes on cigarettes
what you're starting to hear in the
scientific community is one of the ways
to curb some of
these massive health issues
is to start taxing sugar in a profound
way this study comes out and says
not only is sugar contributing to
obesity and type 2 diabetes and
cardiovascular diseases
like heart disease but now we can say
almost beyond a shadow of a doubt that
cancer
can uh is associated with sugar intake
as well
that's a lot so what that's the geek
minute for today
so whatever's going on in your heart in
your home or your head i'm here to stand
with you give me a call at
1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-3291
or you can go to johndaloni.com
show fill out the form and it will go
directly to kelly daniel the one and
only
and she will see about getting you on
the show all right let's go straight to
the calls we've got
a lineup today good folks this one's
gonna be a good one all right let's go
to nicole in cincinnati ohio
nicole how in the world are you today
i'm doing really well john how are you
i'm doing so well so well so how can i
help this morning
it's this afternoon we used to shoot the
show in the morning and i'm just used to
saying good morning but it's the
afternoon
how in the afternoon are you
very good cold and snowy oh good deal it
is not that here in nashville but
very cool so how can i help so
um a few months ago my brother called my
husband a racist
on facebook in public and essentially
he double during this conversation uh
he would not explain why he felt my
husband
right like my husband posted a meme and
my brother would not explain why he
thought it was racist
and essentially my husband unfriended
him because my husband wasn't going to
continue to be attacked
i don't feel that the meme was racist
but now
my brother and i we haven't spoken and
to be honest i don't know that i care to
speak to him
um our family has been really close all
these years and i just feel like now
we're kind of uh like everything else
kind of falling apart
and i just i'm not sure how to resolve
this conflict or even how to approach it
well it doesn't sound like you want to
resolve it do you
i do but i also don't like being
attacked
okay so let's back out a little bit
you said your family's been close all
these years
i would suggest that if one comment
on facebook
would lead to we're not even gonna talk
anymore
i'm not you're not worth a phone call
you're not worth an offline text like
hey what's going on man
especially though you're not worth a
phone call i'm going to let that go
through thanksgiving
i'm assuming i'm going to let that get
up on the christmas season i'm not even
going to
reach out to you and as you said it's
not even i don't even want to
i would suggest y'all weren't that close
so what happened before this
usually people don't just fire off and
and say hey you're a racist
without already there's there's some
seeds of
dissension some seeds of dislike
underneath
this placid smooth you know stream we
have
flowing down here so we all really that
close or everyone just play nice until
something blew up
well i wouldn't say that we i mean we
weren't like calling each other every
day but
i mean on my end i didn't have any issue
with him
um and to be quick also he spent through
college
in cincinnati but then he moved across
the country now he's on
the west coast so and he seems to be
doing well out there
but we were never close enough to colin
every day but we never had any real
like we never had any issues and so
nicole when
i mean your husband posts a meme and
man i tell you what it is everything i
have to not ask what the meme was but
let's don't do that
okay let's a assume that it wasn't
racist
and your brother put something out there
that was inflammatory
he just lobs a grenade onto somebody
else's facebook platform
which by the way is an imaginary world
it's not real
none of this is real so when you
originally when you said
he put something on facebook and called
him it in public
he didn't he put it on facebook but
that's that's another that's a whole
other conversation
so he posted on facebook why in the
world would you not call him
right away and say what are you doing
man
why would you not engage that
my brother can be really difficult to
talk to and
tends to be argumentative and his it's
his way on the highway
but right now it's your way or the
highway you did a thing so highway
so it sounds like y'all are both very
similar is that fair
that's fair or he's more aggressive and
you're more
from the one down position you won't
sink the ship from up top you'll just
pull it down underneath
right both are power moves right they're
just done differently
um so do you want to talk to your
brother anymore
are you are you i'd like it to go back
like i'd like it to go back to how it
used to be
and like i don't want i i want our
family to be whole again
um and again i guess i should also say
on the same day he went after my
cousin's husband and called him a racist
troll
okay and my mother suggested that maybe
there's something
she wouldn't tell me what it was but she
suggested maybe something's going on
with your brother
and you don't understand what's going on
with him and i can get that benefit of
the doubt
but i guess i'm looking for an apology
that i'm never going to get and that's
how i feel like we could
mend this yeah see
but he's not going to apologize well and
it won't make it any better
you're not going to feel vindicated or
validated
and in fact the person with the
challenge here is you
my goodness man your brother is doing
something out of character
he's just calling people racist across
your family
your mom knows for a fact that he's
hurting and his sister didn't reach out
to say
dude what is going on
right and that's fair it seems like
if you don't want to talk to him be at
peace with your boundaries
somebody went after my husband i'm
through with you one strike you're out
i'm done
my guess is it's not one strike your
brother's probably been a jerk before
right or outspoken and loud and leans on
people etc
and let me just pass this along
nobody has been their best self the last
nine months
nobody the last nine months have been
hard right it's been hard with
covid it's been hard with cities on fire
it's been hard with race relations it's
been hard
all across the board with so many
different things
economically it's been a disaster
politically it's been a
hurricane blizzard diarrhea storm it's
just been a mess
and so you have a one of two choice and
usually i don't i can't distill a call
down and
into something this simple but you can
either a
call your brother and say dude what's
going on are you okay
or you can just stand firm on your
convictions that you
posted a line on the internets about my
husband i'm through with you we're done
and you can contact your family and say
everyone's welcome at my house for
christmas except my brother
and we're moving on not together but
what you can't have
is a desire to have your family back to
the way it was that's a fantasy that's
gone okay
there's a rift there and again my guess
is this rift has existed between your
husband and him for a while
but it is what it is and you can either
address the rift head on which is what
adults would do with
you going directly to your brother not
through your mom or anybody
or you can just call it call it over
what do you want to do usually i just
leave the call there but i'm interested
what do you want to do
i think i i think reaching out is a good
idea um
and i i guess i did forget to say that
he called my husband a week later and
then he continued to double down and
call them a race post
so so here here's the million dollar
question
is there a chance what your husband
posted was offensive
i'm sure someone's offended out there
but the majority of
that's not the question that's a passive
lukewarm
response is there a chance that some
that what your husband posted was
offensive
honestly no okay honestly
to be hon to be perfectly honest i i
actually like the post
okay so and several other family members
and
like the post i'm really and i'm willing
to call him and i'm willing to talk to
him
but are you willing to be your biggest
hold on are you willing for him to be
your brother and you'll have different
political views
are you willing to
for him to still be your brother who you
love and you will defend
and you have differing opinions over
what is racist and what is not
why is that why is that a deal breaker
i guess for me and i guess where it
confuses me is how we were raised if
someone was a racist
we generally did not continue
interacting with that person
i saw that as a really bad thing so for
my brother to be a grown adult
i was being raised in the same house i
guess i'm confused and maybe i should
ask him you know more about what he
thinks racism is and things like that
and if we can like you're suggesting
disagree to disagree or or
you could learn something
right you could enter this and say
this is not like you this isn't how we
were raised
this is not who we are
what are you seeing that i'm not seeing
like let's stop let's don't call each
other names
and i'm using this tone of voice on
purpose right
but what are what am i not seeing
because i don't i can't wrap my head
around it
and if your brother yells at you and
says you're an idiot that's just because
you're
this and fills in the blank well yeah
now he is he is ex
he is the immature one right and i'm not
saying he wasn't immature in the first
place
what i'm saying is this i have
been working in and among race issues
my entire professional career
and i have learned a lot this season
a lot because one of the cornerstone
moments
for me one of the cornerstone takeaways
is i need to shut my mouth
a lot more and listen a lot more
and so my initial response to certain
things when i would see a post if you
will
or hear a news conference or hear a
speech or read a book was
i don't think that's right that's been
my historical speech or i would go
lean in and say hey here's my response
to this
this season no more this season
i will read something that i don't fully
wrap my head around or
the data doesn't make sense or usually
it's somebody's experience is way
different than mine
and now i've got a core group of people
that i'll reach out to and say hey help
me walk through this i'm not i'm not
fully grasping it
and i seek first to listen
not first to defend first to
learn not to explain
now does that make what your brother did
right no right
just lobbing that as a grenade is not
helpful
at all it doesn't solve any problems if
somebody sees an offensive meme
from somebody that they love
and you actually are invested in
changing somebody's heart then call them
on the phone and say hey by the way dude
that's not cool
i have a a several close friends
over the years who have pulled me aside
and said hey don't say it like that
um i see where your heart's at delaney
we know you well that's not how you say
that
right let's let's do this another way
and even to the point that
i would have people that i would call
and say i'm about to go give a speech on
this i'm going to do a
academic presentation at this particular
conference on this topic
is this the right way to say this and
they would say
no don't say that you idiot say it like
this
and i was so grateful to have them in my
life
but just lob and grenades you're this
you're that it
solves nothing other than it makes you
feel superior for a minute
and we have enough superiority going on
guys let's stop all that nonsense
if you actually see somebody that posts
something that's hurtful that says
something that's hurtful
and you want to make a difference in
their life and in the world
privately go to that person and say hey
you are hurting people you got to stop
here's what this actually means here's
the history here
and then if they choose to say i think
you're an idiot and i'm going to say it
louder
well then they've made their decision
and feel free to walk away
but man
family members interacting
over facebook is one of the core roots
of this
of this issue and nicole your family's
not the only one
good people stop interacting on social
media stop interacting
via these platforms
call each other facetime one another if
your brother or sister is hurting call
them on the phone and say are you okay
and none of us like i've already said
have were our best this year
all of us have said things and done
things and thought things and leaned
into things
that were not right that we're not good
and none of us have been at our best
during certain moments some of us
have grown some of us have fallen
backwards some of us most of us have
done all those things
but all that to say when somebody's
hurting and they say something stupid
when somebody's hurting and they
lash out
be graceful don't just sit there with
your
hands clenched tight waiting for a
an apology that may never come choose to
forgive put that brick down and you move
on with your life
but for god's sake pick up pick up a
telephone so nicole i usually don't do
this but call your brother call him
tonight and say
i love you and i'm i can't shake the
feeling that you're hurting
and you said some things that hurt
me or hurt my husband that hurt our
family but i think something's deeper is
going on what's going on
and i don't think what was put up there
was racist in fact i liked it
can you teach me where you're coming
from and
enter that conversation that way and
then if your brother's an idiot then you
you and your husband have to sit down
and draw a boundary and say
we wanted this fantasy of a whole family
it's not coming it's not going to happen
and we got to move on right so thank you
so much for that call nicole
i do know this i know millions of people
across the country are dealing with that
right now so i appreciate you having the
courage to call and talk through that
but let's all be people that are slow to
respond slow to anger
quick to pick up a telephone quick to
look somebody in the eye and say hey
hey hey hey hold on let's back up and be
relational beings first what's going on
so thanks for that call all right let's
go to
dan in oklahoma city dan the man what is
up my man how are we doing
hey dr d how's it going i'm doing all
right
um how can i help today man yeah um
i'll try to sum up what has happened
real quick and then i'll
i'll dive in just a little bit a couple
days ago
i got a call from my co-worship leader
and she said that she was stepping down
immediately due to some
uh inappropriate text that her and my
pastor have
been having in this last week and
so are you on staff at this church yes i
am
yes i'm a me and her are co-worship
leaders
and we have a band about eight people
and me and her just live together
i joined this church about a year ago
and
i this pastor is one of my dearest
friends
and so just to dive into that phone call
a little bit
at the very first of the phone call she
wouldn't give me any details she just
said that she was stepping down
because of some circumstances that had
happened and she would not
tell me what was going on she just kept
saying that this would put me
in a corner if i knew but then she'd
kind of give me some hints along the way
and i honestly i'll be honest i did pry
quite a bit
and and then i asked her if i swore to
secrecy
if she would tell me oh no no dan
yeah yeah so you sort of secrecy and
then she threw a grenade at you huh
well and she said she wouldn't tell me
and i and and then i
uh all she would tell me is she said
this had nothing to do with with the
band and nothing to do with the sound
people nothing to do with the church
board
and she said that's all she would tell
me as far as leadership would go
and she'd just give me these hints and
then i finally guessed it and then she
told me
and um and this this pastor is actually
one of my dearest friends he's a mentor
to me he's given me marital advice
before
um and she just she just kept telling me
that she felt like she had to fall on
the sword for this one and that she was
only 25
to blame but she she said she had kind
of toyed around a little bit to see
if he was serious and test the waters
and she said that she wasn't proud of it
but this wasn't her first rodeo
with doing this before sure and
um so let's hold on so i want to stop
with her
let's just put her she's made this phone
call now i want to talk about you
okay so for people who are not in the
church world
and people who are not on staff at a
church
here's what i'm hearing really quick is
the complexity here
you have a co-worker who swore you to
secrecy
but she really wanted you to pry and
find out
which you pride and you found out that
she was being inappropriate with
your boss who happens to be the senior
pastor and
your good friend and a spiritual advisor
to you
and a marriage advisor to you and she
chose to step down
and the one side of the story you have
here is that it was mostly him but
i went fishing and i've done this before
and
i know how to do this but it was mostly
him and so
you are in eight different rocks and a
hard place it feels like you're not but
it feels like it
yeah and rock number one is i swore i
wouldn't tell
rock number two is i have a friend who
by any stretch of the imagination
friendship is about
vulnerability and friendship is about
openness and friendships about
accountability
and then number three how are you going
to worship at a church where the boss is
doing that
right no yes i'm sorry this is heavy but
yes
no it i mean it it's very heavy and i
don't want to make light of it but your
path forward is relatively simple
okay so you'll hear me say this a lot on
this show cause it's
our life and it is not by your hand but
in your lap
okay so somebody just dropped something
in your lap and now you got to deal with
it did you cause it no
is it your fault no but you do have a
responsibility to deal with that
and that can be trashing that's blowing
down your street
that can be a um
neighbor who you've got to go knock on
the door and have a hard conversation
with it could be a teacher that treats
your kid wrong whatever the thing is
it's not you didn't cause it but now you
got to deal with it right that's
life how old are you man
i am 27. all right so if you haven't
experienced this before this will be a
hardest thing you've ever walked through
and it will be a cornerstone of who you
become
the minister you become the pastor you
become
and if you choose to quit all this and
get out and go sell insurance
it's going to be a cornerstone of the
person you become because you're going
to have to do something hard
okay yeah and for everybody out there
never ever ever say the words
i promise i won't tell
i promise i won't tell because you never
know what someone's going to put
on you you never know what someone's
going to put on you and
you learn this the hard way dan but
i am not in the business if somebody
doesn't want to tell me i'm going to
move on with my life
yeah you know what i mean that is their
secret their burden their whatever to
carry
but the next time you'll know that if
someone calls and says hey i have to
emergency step down there's some things
that happen behind closed doors and i
gotta go
then you will say oh my gosh i'll be
thinking about you we'll be praying for
you
i wish you the best of luck and if i
could ever be of service you know her
how to get a hold of me and then you
hang up and let him go and then your
next call is to the boss
right not to pry from that person and
you let the boss know that somebody said
something like
uncouth is going on but anyway that's
where we're at right now right so
your path forward and again i feel like
i'm doing this in the second call in a
row here
to being pretty prescriptive but you got
to let her know
that you shouldn't have pride you did
and you can't keep that that
confidential period
and the next thing you have to do is go
directly to your friend
in person and say here's what's in my
lap
yep and you got to do that i agree
and that's that's honestly i just needed
the permission to do that because
i know that you know scripture says in
in matthew to confront your neighbor
if if they are sinning and if this is
true and
um and so i i feel like i i owe him the
respect and
to do this and and just to to let you
know also and i feel like this is
important to share but
what's even more crazy is that my pastor
and his wife in two different situations
about a month ago privately with me let
me know
and and they let me know to be aware
of this other worship leader and that
she's not happy in her marriage and that
to not be alone in situations with her
because
she uh prize for attention and i'm
a kind of guy that just loves to love
people and they said that
you know it can be taken as flirtatious
if someone wants attention
and uh what's crazy is my pastor even
said i just want you to be aware and i
don't want you to ever be alone in
situations with her
just to protect your marriage because it
could always be a he shed she said thing
and i don't ever want to put you in that
predicament
so that's why i'm so confused well and
here's
where this is this is really important
this is why you
with no fanfare no drama no
calling in the calvary this is why you
as a grown man
go sit down one on one with your other
grown man friend
okay and you say here's what i was told
i have a feeling that he may pull his
phone out and say
i'll show you what happened and your
eyes will bug out of your head once you
get the other side of the story
okay and reserve your judgments reserve
your grenades for him
reserve your disdain for him and the
role of the church and
partridge in a pear tree here's the
thing he may be a scumbag
he may have had one one
singular lap lapse in judgment one
yep and he may have received a bunch of
crazy text messages from somebody
immediately showed his wife immediately
gone to his
his bosses right the eldership or
whatever leaders are at your particular
denomination
and said whoa and to which
somebody stepped in and said you need to
resign right away to this other worship
leader
she did and now she's spinning story you
know all that to say is you don't know
yeah and so your job is to go sit down
and say
here's what was told to me and
it's my job as your friend who loves you
and um who has invested in you and
you've invested in me
to put this out there and know that this
is being said about you
and this is out there and then let him
speak
and here's the thing dan you may not get
resolution on this
that's what i'm worried about right
sometimes your resolution is going to be
i did the right thing and then the truth
will find its way out
sometimes the resolution on something is
finding another
side of a story right um if you're great
friends with him and he denies the whole
thing you may say dude show me your text
right now
and he may pull your phone out right
away right
or you may be able to say dude can you
can you show me and i've got friends in
my life who would do that to me
by the way yeah right um and is your
heart going to be beating fast yes is
this going to be
awkward yes is this going to be
uncomfortable yes
but is this what you have to do yeah it
is
it is if you get a sense that he's lying
and shady
and like skeptical and weird
then it's fair to put him on notice that
i'm gonna give this seven days and then
i'm gonna go talk to
to my bosses there at the church if i
think you're not being honest with me
then
i've got a responsibility to this this
entire group of people who attend this
church
who work at this place um that they
know what was dropped in my lap
but i think the right thing to do is to
go to him directly first right
now quick aside and dan i'm just i'm not
speaking to you i'm speaking anybody
else listening to this
if this is a kid in the youth group
whole different conversation
this is a kid in the youth group if this
is a
kid in like uh sunday school
then we're calling in the calvary we're
turning all the lights on in the
building and we'll figure stuff out
later
but that's when i'm going to have a much
louder conversation
than a personal hey someone just quit
and they said it was because you were
making them feel uncomfortable they said
it was because you
were hitting on them and you're married
they're married something feels oogy
about this and they said they had to
quit
dude what in the world this doesn't
sound like you this isn't the guy i know
this isn't the
pastor that i know but i have to sit
down and look your eye and say
i'm not cool with this what's going on
so that's my thoughts dan i appreciate
the call
and again that's a lot of responsibility
for a 27 year old
and that's what you signed up for you're
in this role for a reason
i do want you to do this i want you to
have this hard conversation
and please email me back please call me
back i'd love to have you back on the
show and let everybody know how that
conversation went
um one of the things that we don't do
well as a culture as a society is have
hard conversations and so i want to hear
how it went
and it may help for you to write bullet
points down right
it may be helpful for you to practice
this conversation
with your wife or in the mirror or
whatever that may be but
uh make sure you are clear-headed and
clear minded
and go talk to your friend he deserves
that you deserve that
and the people in that church deserve
that so thank you so much all right
let's take one more call let's go to
john in
san francisco california john what's up
hi dr doug deloney how are you i'm good
man i'm good how are you
uh well i'm struggling and i need a
little bit of help
all right brother you called the right
place how can i help yeah
uh i think you called the right place i
don't know what you're struggling with
i kind of said that presumptively but
let's go for it let's see if we can
figure it out
so i'm married and my question is how do
we navigate
marriage and raising two kids with
now two very different beliefs a little
backstory is
we've been married for seven years
dating for three prior to that
uh we have two kids ages three and five
uh my wife growing up was a jehovah's
witness
she stepped away from the faith about
late teens
um she
she wasn't in it when we were dating so
she had talked about it a little bit
but wasn't a part of it but now all of a
sudden she wants to go back
and she actually is going back okay um
what makes it hard is their their
beliefs are
are strongly different uh no birthdays
no holidays
um i feel like a single parent
yeah number one
i hate that for you john because your
whole world just got turned upside down
and i'm
i am just gonna sit here for a second
and grieve with you it sucks man
and i hate that for you um
what conversation does a junior wife
have leading up to this does she just
come in one day and lay this on you
has she been thinking about this has
there been um
challenges in your marriage or is this
just out of the blue
she she's mentioned it before um
and i think a big push is her mom okay
who's not around she's east coast so
we're west coast um
her mom is a big influence on her and so
i think uh
covet is also another issue she brought
that up saying that
as she started talking about prophecies
and how things are starting to come true
and
uh and the the faith she wants what they
believe in to happen
for her and the kids
she would like me to join in on it and
i'm just not
i don't agree with that right
so what do you want to do
[Music]
that's that's where i'm i'm stuck we're
we love each other we're married we're
we're in it for the long haul but now
now it's
our way of life is turned upside down
and
i i just don't know what to do going
forward
okay for those again for those
listening to this who aren't in these
universes i want to to spell
a broader picture um
often folks who aren't in any particular
faith
community or are in faith communities
that
may be more universal in nature there
are certain faith communities that
have a deep heartfelt ideation that
if it doesn't isn't happen this way
somebody's soul is going to be tortured
forever and
these conversations can be existential
in nature when
my version of endings and your version
of endings don't match
it's not simply a matter of well you can
go to that building on sunday and i'll
go to this building and then we'll just
meet up for lunch
it can be much deeper than that right
john right
okay one of their beliefs was uh blood
transfusions she does not believe in
that
okay and so god forbid something happens
and she's
with the kids and one of them gets hurt
she's not gonna agree to
saving her child's life right so
here's here's the
man i'm wading into deep waters here but
here's the reality
you're fortunate in this conversation
because you and your wife both love each
other
okay and you have to start from that
place
and you need to have a conversation that
is less about religion
less about beliefs and more about
how are we going to honor and take care
of these kids well
she makes this big transition while you
come to terms with what your new
relationship is going to look like
and what the day to day is gonna look
like what the week to week what the
month to month year to year is gonna
look like
and then you need to get into the nitty
gritty and some of these transitions in
your mind are gonna be bigger than they
are
in reality meaning you're gonna have
conjured up in your head
this and this and this um she's not if
your kid's in a car wreck
and they're racing her to the hospital
she's gonna sign a paper and say no
blood transfusion i'm gonna let my kid
die on the table
so you need to know the doctors won't
let that happen
um but there may be other alternatives
where you say
my kids will get the medical care that
they need i will not budge on that
period right um i am going to throw
my child a birthday party period
okay and so what you need to get in your
head is
the non-negotiables right and
have a conversation with your wife ask
her what are the non-negotiables
because now she gets both sides right
she's been there she left she was
um with you and you're are you just in a
protestant faith uh
uh yeah okay so you're she's been in
that world
and then she transitioned out my guess
is she's going to transition again
in a number of years right she will move
around in these conversations and so
what i want you to do is to have your
non-negotiables have heard on
negotiables and y'all sit down and talk
through them
okay if you find a situation where your
kids aren't safe you've got a bigger
problem
okay right or you believe your kids
aren't safe you have a larger issue here
um if my guess is it's not going to be
the case
correct it might be but probably not
okay
my guess is there's going to be a lot
more similarity than you think
and the rug got pulled out from under
you in a pretty significant
way and my guess is she's hurting too
she's trying to figure this out as well
so number one you're gonna get there in
love you're gonna figure out what is
best for our kids
and then you're gonna continue to double
down on connection and see if there's
any sort and i may be nuts here but any
sort
of compromise moving forward
right and it may be knowles holds no
holds barred
i am taking my kids to this place we are
doing this thing
at which point you and her need to go
see a marriage counselor immediately
because then your marriage is going to
be on life support
okay okay i know you're committed to it
but if you have strong protestant
beliefs and you have
kids if you have strong values and
beliefs of any sort
and somebody else particularly your wife
is imposing different values and beliefs
on your kids
that that contradict those there's no
way your marriage survives that
okay that if you don't have a spirit of
love and connection and compromise there
okay
and here's here's the magic i want you
to be open with your kids
as you have these conversations okay
how old are they three and five three
and five okay so
hard now because she is she's obviously
teaching what she believes now and so
and they're not doing this out of spite
or hate or anything but
they'll make comments oh dad doesn't
know jehovah
or sure stuff like that or why isn't
that a pray to jehovah
it's they're they're innocent kids but
that's her teaching
them this stuff and it's it's hard it's
hard to sit at the dinner table and do
that it is
and if it aligns with your values and
beliefs you need to let her know that
i'm also going to tell this story
one about jesus one about who i believe
in one about who
i believe this how this narrative plays
and it's going to feel like you're
you're going to throw these kids into a
tizzy and they're not going to know up
from down and side to side
um you're not they're going to hear the
integrity in your voice you're going to
hear the integrity in your wife
and they're going to hear two adults
approaching a problem having different
outcomes but they're all going to be
rooted in connection there does that
make sense
it does it does and kids are incredibly
resilient
they understand like here's a here's
this is a this is an off the wall
example if it's a terrible one
don't send me mean cards and letters
whatever um
i'm late to everything i try so
hard john i can't tell you how hard i
try
my wife is 15 minutes early to
everything
okay and it drives me crazy that we
leave that much time on the table we
just get somewhere and we
sit and people are still filing in and
it drives her crazy that we are always
running in and we're always late right
right
my kids know that i'm trying
i really am i'm putting some things in
place i'm constantly
working towards discipline and it's a
discipline issue dude i wish it was
something
you know psychosomatic it's discipline
for me
and she is constantly working on having
a little more fun in life
right loosening up a little bit and my
kids see
two parents who are both people of
integrity both people who have values
both people who have
beliefs and who are approaching going to
the movies differently does that make
sense
yeah so there's not the existential
weight here right there's not the idea
of what's going to happen in the
afterlife and all those other
conversations
but there no is if you approach your
kids in love
you approach your kids with connection
they're going to be able to
um they're going to be able to hear and
see you guys
okay they love us i'm figuring this out
i'm figuring that out it's when she says
you cannot mention jesus at my house
again then you are going to have a
problem or when you turn to her and say
you will not talk about praying to
jehovah again in this home
then you are going to have a problem
right
so ultimately you know i'm going gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna back out
you all need to go see a marriage
counselor now right
you only need to go see a marriage
counselor now you need to go talk to
somebody now and begin to work through
some of the
um what this means have somebody else
navigate this with you
your non-negotiables the things that are
you're able to compromise
what birthdays and holidays are going to
look like what church service is going
to look like what
we're going to tell our kids about end
times prophecies verse
this is one of many many many many many
pandemics that have happened in our
in the history of people and so on and
so on and so forth right
um
but double down in love you still love
this lady she still loves you
and that's a great place for you to
start okay
sit down tonight with her and say we're
going to talk about our kids we're going
to talk about the non-negotiables we're
going to go from there
john thank you so much for this call i
do want to know how that conversation
happens
how it goes so call me back let me know
how it goes and let me know how the
non-negotiables call my guess is i'm
almost positive
there's going to be very very few very
few things at the end of the day
that you'll have to go to war on right
now eventually you will eventually have
to butt heads in a hard way
and you'll have to save for me and my
house she'll say for me and my house and
you're gonna have to have some hard hard
conversations
but for right now in the season of
transition the season of pain
double down on love doubled on
non-negotiables and make sure those kids
are loved and connected
all right so as we wrap up the show
let's see here i've got let's go with
this one
let's go with this one actually you know
what no that's two on the nose for today
can't do that one brother i was gonna do
that one that would sound like i set
john up
john i did not this is just a song was
just sitting up here we'll do that some
other show
all right we're gonna go with the 1991
i mean is this the top five greatest
songs ever written
by the one and only mark cone and it's a
song about tennessee it's called walking
in memphis and he goes like this
i put on my blue suede shoes and i
boarded the plane
touched down in the land of the delta
blues in the middle
of the pouring rain wc handy won't you
look down over me
yeah i got a first class ticket but i'm
as blue as a boy can be
saw the ghost of elvis on union avenue i
followed him up to the gates of
graceland
then i watched him walk right through
now security they didn't see him
they just hovered around his tomb but
there's a pretty little thing waiting
for the king down in the jungle room
then i'm walking in memphis i was
walking with my 10 feet
off of beale walking in memphis
but do i really feel the way i feel mark
cohn
love it this is the dr john deloney show